abone ol
e herkese merhaba Ben sarı saçlı çenenin
altına doğru uzanıyor kahverengi gözlü
orta yaşlı merdiven ceketli beyaz
gömlekle avukatım yanındaki çok kıymetli
Yol Arkadaşım rehber Köpeğim Kara siyah
bi Labrador altı yaşında üzerinde
tasması var Ve lütfen Dokunmayın sahibim
görmüyor rehberlik yapıyorum diyor o
uyuma ve horlamaya çok severek olarak
altı yaşındaydım hakim olan dedem
ve mesleğini anlattı hak ve hukuk
kavramını öğrendim kendisinden çok
konuştuğum için Avukat olmamı karar
verdik dedeme söz verdim
bu ilkokul dörde başlamadan önceki
yazdığımı Müzik dersinde başlamıştım
piyano çalmayı öğreniyordum
12 dersimiz da satırların arasında
notaları yazmamaya başladım öğretmenim
Gözlüğümü takar mısın dedi benim
gözlüğüm yoktu basit bir yok problemi
gibi düşündüm ama aslında öyle değildi
hastaneler Doktorlar Yurtiçi yurtdışı
Anladık ki bunun çaresi yok bununla
yaşamayı öğrenmek zorundaydık annem
babam çok güçlüydü ve hayattan kopma
asla izin vermedi Annem bulaşık
makinesine yardım eder misin yatağını
mısın demeye devam etti hiçbir
zaman bana hissettirme diler oradaki
dedim okul değiştirmiştim okul görevlisi
sınıfa geldi bir arkadaşınız görmüyor
yardımcı olabilir misiniz dedi kimse
yanıma oturmadı
aritmal masasına oturup kendimi yönetici
gibi ilan edip evlenmeye başladım ve
tahtayı defterine geçiriyordum okuma
parçalarını ezberlediğim için hafızamı
küvet kuvvetlendir dim vs dayıcığım
beden öğretmenim
tüm arkadaşlarımı köprüden atladı sıra
bana gelmişti Anne çok atlamayı
istiyordum yandan gördüm için biraz
zorlanabilir dim düşük görmeden dolayı
ama örtülü de desteğine yaptım Ondan
sonraki formülün hep hayalet hedefle
bağışlar oldu de son daydım İstanbul
Üniversitesi hukuk fakültesini kazanmayı
çok istiyordum Annemle babam daha kolay
bir üniversite ve bölüm tercih
edebilirsin tüm kararların arkasındayız
Ama Karar verirsen dönmek yok dediler
Ben zaten kararımı vermiştim İstanbul
Üniversitesi hukuk fakültesini ilk
tercih Ben sandım o kapıdan girmek benim
için dünyanın en mutlu olaylarından
biriydi
Ben okulu bitirdim sonra Amerika'da kısa
dönem ve eğitim aldım engelli için
sistem oturmuştu ve nasıl yardım edecek
yeni videolarda Türkiye'ye geldiğimde
çalışmaya başladım birçok STK da gönüllü
olarak çalışmalar yapıyordum görme kaybı
olan kişilerin işe yerleştirilmesi ve
eğitimin detek olmak gibi tabi bu sırada
görme kaybı hızla artıyordu
2014 senesiydi
Ya kanka
ve birleşik Krallığı Büyükelçisi olarak
sayın retreat Mor ve sevgili mecbur
atandı televizyona sevgili Mecnun görme
kaybı olduğunu duymuştum ama indir
Ticaret Odası Derneği'nin onları
dansında düzenlediği davette kadar
detaylı bilmiyordum ilk ile tanıştım
mucize gibiydi o kadar enerji O kadar
hareketli bir insanlık çok etkilendim bu
ve her şeyimiz aynıydı daha önce görme
engelli arkadaşım birkaç tane olmuştu
Ama Mac ile aynı yaşta aynı görme oranı
ve karşında başarısıyla Dur dur Rapper
köpeği sizlerle birlikte bağımsızlar
hareketi o kadar güzeldi ki kendisini
Benim de görme kalbim azalıyor Ben
Rehber köpek nasıl edinebilirim diye
sordum şekerle karışık dernek kuralım
adını hiç düşünmedim tamam dedim
ve dernek tüzüğüne hazırlar hazırlama
ne İngiltere'ye gittim rehber köpekler
okulunu derneklerini gezdim yüzyıllar
yazılı önce yapılan bir insandı ve o
kadar başarılıydı mükemmel 2mg adını Biz
bu sene nasıl kurabiliriz bu dediğimde
mükemmelin karşıdır yeri başlıyoruz dedi
dünyanın birçok yerinde rehber köpek
Okulu Kur'an en hızlı Türkiye davet
ettik O bize bir program hazırladığı
programda Golden veya labrador cinsi 8
haftalık köpeği etmenizin denetimi
alacağız bir yılına gönüllü bakıcı
ailelerimize vereceğiz veteriner mama
Eğitim Hizmetleri Biz de yemin edeceğiz
aile Otur Kalk bekle gibi pozitif
eğitimi yavru köpeğimize verecek sevgisi
ile birlikte Çünkü her şeyi satın
alabilirsiniz ama ailenin vardı o sevgi
satın alamazsınız müthiş bir fedakarlık
O bir yıldız tamamlayan Dostlarımı yavru
köpeklerimiz en az üç ay En fazla altı
ay rehber köpek eğitimine girecek ve
sonrasında tamamen bedelsiz olarak refah
köpeklerimizi görme engellilere
eleştirecek bir program Tamam çok fazla
deneyim bu
ve bu süreci tamamlandıktan sonra
Kara'nın Haberi geldi kara ile
izleyecektik hayatıma yeni bir arkadaşım
girecekti ve bağımsız hareketin için
artık yola çıkacaktık
oy kara ile ilgili için Tamam
kameraların karşısındaydı kralın kayısı
elimdeydi Dizimin aşağısı tutmadığı
hatırlıyorum belgesel çekimi yapılıyor
duydum Ege yetiştiren dinky ve tam
karşımızda yaydık arada Hani Hem beni
çok seviyordu hem de onu İsrail'e karşı
bir minnet borcu varmışçasına ona
bakıyordu
abone ol
bu ve o gün kayısını yürümeye molasını
ver Meyve suyunu vermeyi öğren
12 daydı aynı odada uyuyacak tık O kadar
yorgunum ki bu ışıkları açık İkimiz de
uyuya kalmışız geçerse bir tahta sesi
gibi bir ses geldi aynı kalktım ne
oluyor diye bir baktım Kara uyuyormuş
sabahleyin uyandığımızda tankio yıl
karşılaşmamız gibi Hasret giderdik
ardından kayısı alıyorum tasması daha
bana teslim edilmemiştir 4 hafta sonu
bir eğitim tamamlanınca Artvin bahçesine
indik ve o kadar yorgunum ki karaviran
dayımdan gitti eyvah dedim Ekinler
yaparken de mi kaçırdım rezil oldum
Hayır değil de kara dizine bizi mi
kafasını koydum Hayır dostum sende
birlikte birçok şey yapacağız da
hocasını yanındaydı onu tarama ki şimdi
fırçalamak iki tam birbirine emanet de o
Benim iki kızım oldu bende onu
hizmetkârı ikimiz yollarda yaydık an
önce Ankara'daki Eğitimi bittikten sonra
İstanbul'a ne gitar
Ben Ankara'dan İstanbul'a gitmiş bir
uçak yolculuğu du ama aslında artık
yeni başlamış da her şey İstanbul'da
herkesin imkansız yapamazsın dediği
metrobüse gidecektik metrobüse
geldiğimizde güvenlik görevlisine
Birleşmiş Milletler engelli hakları
satış masa taraf olduğumuzu estetiğine
katkı olduğunu anlatırken köpeğiniz mi
görmüyor dedim Yok ben görmüyorum dedi
ve ardından metrobüse bindik koltuğa
oturduk göre koltuğun altına geçti on
değil mi nefes aldığımı hissediyorum
çünkü bizden sonra köpek köpek olacak
herkese toplutaşım yolunu açmaya
başlamıştık imkansız denilen olmuştu
Marmaray tren vapur Artık tüm Toplu
taşıma araçlarını Deniz eksik ve
başardık
Bu Bir Başka hayalimi daha vardı Ben
kara ile birlikte Londra'da uzun
yürüyüşler yapmayı çok hayal etmiştim
eve gittik Kara'yla n14u uzun bir
yürüyüş yaptık ve senin yardımıyla da
yönümüzü bulduk kralın çalışırken en
büyük ihtiyacı sevgilim ona iltifat
etmem gerekiyor kare harikasın
muhteşemsin telefon konuşmam lazım
yanında bir olursa ona konuşmam
gerekiyor o aramızdaki bu kuvvetli bir
şekilde sağlam tutmamız lazım
girdiğimizde
emanetiniz ve
o sıra bu operaya geldi bulunduğumuz
sahnede kare ile birlikte ilk Opera muz
izledik Devlet Tiyatrosu gerekiyordu
çünkü rehber köpek alıcıların
gidebileceği yerlerden biriydi Devlet
Tiyatrosu'nda
oy kara ile birlikte prova yapmamızı
istediler davulcu geldi kadının kulağına
doğru davul çaldı Kara Kafasını kaldırıp
tekrar koydu
ardından sanatçı Bu kitapları yere attı
diğer tarafa doğru kara yine hiç hareket
yapmadı Evet artık devlet tiyatrosunu
kapısı açılmıştı bize
bu heyecanı bütün ilkleri
gerçekleştirmeye başladık gönüllü
sayımız artık kahramanlarımız Artı Artık
her şey yavaş yavaş yoluna girmeye
başlamıştır sürdürebilir ve daha etkili
bir çalışma için karadan sonra gönüllü
olarak çalışmalarını daha da arttırdım
çünkü Kara'nın benim hayatımdaki
bağımsız hareket etkisini o sevgi
gördükten sonra birçok kişiye ulaşmak
istedim
bu
ve fırsat eşitliği insan hakları canlı
hakları çalışmalarından biri
bu daha önce birçok buz pateni gibi
kayak gibi sporlar yaptım ama en çok
istediğim paraşüt yapmak
bu Fethiye bilmişim için gittim Uçar
kadar vaktim vardı ya arkadaşım
yardımıyla paraşütü ayarladık
bu babadağı'na çıktık 1155 metreydi
bu pilot ve eğitim almadan ne yapacağını
anlattı
bu iki kişi Uçucu attık
Ben 10 metre kadar koştuk
bu çatır iki uçtuk Kollarımı bir
salladım Bulutlara yakın olduğunu
hissettim Ülker hissediyordum Eğitmen
betimleyerek öyle denizin üstünde
olduğunu anlattı Kelebekler Vadisi'ni
anlattı sıfır sat eşitliği imkan
verildiği zaman Herşey yapılabilir
Biz bunu başarmak benim için çok büyük
bir keyif oldu
bu engellenen birey olmamak için çok
çabaladı
ama asla pes etmedim
bu Pes etmiyorum çalışmaya devam
edeceğim
Sağ ol Can dostum Kara'nın sevgisiyle de
Biz bunu mutlulukla yapıyorum bizi
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ediyorum
uma